you know i'm kind of jealous of people
that found that in painting for example
they'll be drawing or painting and
listening to so that that's the small
task you do
you're coloring in the lines it's like
this gentle peaceful
slow process
that requires just a small fraction of
your mind and then you can listen some
people listen to podcasts that way some
people listen to music that way
yeah
how do you do it how do you free your
mind
running is one of them
there's a process
so the most
freeing of the mind for me has to go
through a process of a bit of pain for a
bit
so doing something difficult
uh it's just like a
airplane taking off or something so
like for example running the first few
miles would just be just
just first of all
the physical aspect which is like ah
you're so fat you're out of shape you're
this is this is getting old this that
okay that slowly dissipates and then
the demons come in who are like
you should be
you should be getting this and that and
this done you haven't gotten it done
you're like breaking promises all those
kind of voices coming in and after that
maybe mile four it's like [ __ ] it
you just
you just run run with the wind at a very
slow pace but with the wind and then and
then you could think so it's the the
footsteps the physical activity but then
you can deeply think about stuff ideas
sort of design whether it's program
design stuff or
like high level life decisions all those
kinds of things i would say
uh running i used to build bridges from
toothpicks
i used to be a thing it's an engineering
i guess some people like
glued together airplanes and stuff like
that
but the bridge is
such
deeply honest work because at the end of
it you're gonna have to test that bridge
and you're gonna see
how good your work was the little
details but also the big picture do you
use glue or no
yeah you use glue
so it's not pure physics it's it's it's
uh materials engineering too
because uh the way
you want to do it is you actually split
the wood as thin as possible and then
glue it back together because the glue
is really
uh strong except for the arches and
things like that so you're building arch
bridges which is a whole other skill
because you have to bend the wood
and it's so cool because the thing can
hold thousands of times its weight
and then you get to watch it explode at
a certain point
from the pressure and when you do a
really good job it doesn't explode in a
um kind of
some weak point that you didn't
anticipate just kind of starts cracking
everything cracks everything explodes
it's just
pieces fly everywhere
and
it's literally hundreds of hours of work
just explode
in front of you
and that's uh it's a metaphor for life
maybe and it's all for nothing
except for the journey that you took to
get there
you